let's talk about bitcoin
let's do it so imagine you're a diehard
bitcoin person
you wake up and elon musk says
tesla buys one and a half billion
dollars of bitcoin and starts accepting
for
accepting payment for cars what is the
reaction of the
die-hard bitcoin believer when they hear
that story honestly
oh they are through the roof it's
christmas new year's
hanukkah and one day all in one day
because if you oh if you're one of the
guys
the og guys that you bought bitcoin when
it was nothing
and you sit on it um i mean even if you
bought bitcoin
on friday you would have it would have
gone up eight thousand dollars
if you would have just bought it on
friday 38 30.
46. it's at 46.33 right now so tesla
will begin accepting bitcoin the
electronic automaker disclosed an sec
filing on monday citing efforts to
further diversify maximus returns on our
cash and
a first may soon accept this payment as
uh for its cars the move sent bitcoin
higher trading about forty two thousand
dollars
eight a.m i don't know where it's at
right now the year the cryptocurrency
this year the crypto
cryptocurrency has gained 33 percent
shares of automaker have gained 20
percent this year compared to three
percent of smp-500 and seven and a half
percent of
nasdaq composite musk added i think
bitcoin is really on the verge of
getting
broad acceptance by conventional finance
people so
there it is right there broad acceptance
so let me ask you legitimacy so let me
ask you this how high does it go
how high does it go according to experts
they they don't
experts who's an expert they think a
hundred thousand dollars
is where it could go from here maybe but
i don't think that's a big deal though i
don't think it's a hundred thousand
dollars
you think it can go even higher than
that let me know six to 12 months let me
put it to you this way who's bigger than
elon musk in the world right now
nobody nobody bezos might have a say in
that but
no no bezos is tom brady bezos is on
base was on his way out he just became
uh you know andy jazzy no bezos is like
he's not
he's not uh he's not he doesn't grab
attention he's just kind of fading in
the back no bezos doesn't want attention
yeah okay
bezos is biden elon musk is more you
know
trump-esque is what it is okay take the
politics out he likes being relevant
right
so no one's bigger than musk so musk
goes out there and says
bitcoin and not only that tesla the
automaker that's now worth whatever it's
worth that
puts one and a half billion dollars and
they're now accepting payments
yeah i don't know that's a big deal i
don't see this thing going from 42 to
100 thousand well he had bitcoin in his
twitter
i see this i see this thing going 42
to a few hundred so you're buying i i'm
and i'm and i'm
i'm coming from a place of very neutral
like yesterday i was commenting tweeting
about the super bowl
oh you have money on this you have a
brady car do you have a homes card i
said i have no
i don't have any money on this game like
mattress uh
mac who put three and a half million
dollars and he won six million dollars
in houston
and a couple years ago he put 12 million
dollars on the astronauts had to fly
to nevada though to put in the bet he
carried in that little samsonite you
showed the pictures
online online yeah because he had a
picture with like a lot of money i don't
know if that was just like a prop or
something
by the way mattress mac uh jen is from
houston
he says he is the most giving man in the
city and they love him when the
hurricane came if you guys remember
uh the the church joel osteen's church
shut down
he opened up all his mattress stores
saying anybody can come and sleep here
because it's bad condition that's how
that's why the city loves that's crazy
this guy yeah so going back to this
bitcoin
i don't think it's going to go 42 000 to
100 000.
i don't think so i think it's bigger
than that what's interesting though
is because flip it now now let's just
say you now go
and you have wall street the values of
the world
they have funds now they're adding
bitcoin to the portfolio
it's it's it's a so forty two thousand
to a hundred thousand
okay let me ask the question in a
different way would you have
thought a year and a half ago that elon
musk was gonna go from being worth
five ten fifteen billion dollars to two
hundred billion dollars
no don't be surprised if this goes from
42 to like 400.
the interesting thing is that i didn't
that's a don't be surprised yeah
okay meaning it could happen uh i'd be
interesting to see because you know how
p
the hype with bitcoin when it first kind
of blew up towards the tail end of 2017
everyone was buying everyone was
investing they were like oh i'm gonna
put it in
i'm gonna pick one i'm gonna put in a
couple some a couple thousand dollars
it's gonna 100x in three days and then
it crashed
at that point the peak was 19 000. if
you just
held on to that you could have been
stupid enough to buy at the top
and held onto it and it'd still be twice
as much today yeah and that's probably
just
when was that what month this was
december of 2017.
in december of 2000 december 2017 was 19
bucks yeah no 19 000. okay december of
2017
a jordan rookie card was selling for 25
000
if you would have bought one and held on
to that you would have sold it today for
700 000
bitcoin people hate it when i say that
25 000
25 times more that 19 would have been
double
so people people can't take their eye
off
cards as well there's a big move in the
card community right but then but then
if you go a year later
when it went back down to like three
thousand dollars i mean you're looking
at now you're talking now you're talking
my language that's 13.
i'm also saying that because i have a
lot of friends that bought bitcoin
at the peak thinking oh it's going to
keep going yeah it went down they
they were like all right i'm pissed i'm
never going into it like i'm done
like zero i'm not trying to lose more
money however
even buying at the worst time it's a 2x
that's not bad well just for some by the
way this is just so you know i'm
i'm right now bi on bitcoin this is
like go buy you know uh uh that'd be my
uh uh uh opinion on where bitcoin's at
today you were gonna say so no i just
a couple um you know economic lessons
out there for the investors out there
uh hey i wish i would have bought more
bitcoin over the last
couple years i i bought um you know
three four years ago
uh two things obviously buy and hold is
a
that's strategy it's a strategy no
matter whether you're buying bitcoin
or whether you're in the stock market or
whether you're you know have a cobie
card or
whatever it is uh but also sorry about
that but you've done okay with the wins
but also dollar cost averaging is a
strategy
you bought bitcoin when it was at 19.
you bought bitcoin when it was at three
you bought bitcoin when it was at
35. you bought bitcoin was at 40. you're
gonna buy bitcoin at 50. it's gonna
you're gonna buy it when it goes down to
17. dollar cost averaging same with the
market you buy the market stock market
when it's at 19 when it's at 30 when
it's at 18
just continually to buy and hold buy and
hold buy and hold in dollar cost
averaging so
uh just you know put that into your
little uh
cap over there is bitcoin gonna go like
you want to make a prediction next 90
days where bitcoin goes
90 days well with what we've seen
with this gamestop stuff and with
certainly
elon musk and whatever he's doing with
this dogecoin stuff
the market more than ever is easy easier
to manipulate
with a tweet with a comment with wall
street bets kind of getting up there so
more than ever you can move the markets
just with kind of momentum and emotion
rather than
you want to give a number or you want to
give me like a love story here on how
you met your first girlfriend
i mean i think if if if elon's
continuing to do this i think bitcoin
could be on the
uh it could be at 100 000 in the next
six months so you're putting a hundred
thousand six months i'd say
75 next 90 days 75 next 90 days how
about you ppd i don't know guys i think
oh
cool
[Laughter]
i think it's going six figures next 90
days really i think it could so when are
you buying
uh i bought this morning because i'm
gonna go with you right now no no no no
no no
i didn't buy this one i don't want
people to tweet and say pat about this
one i didn't buy this morning but all
i'm saying is i think it's going to go
six figures
wow i just think there's other places
that i can make go ahead why do you
think
uh because i had some notes here why do
you think they they allowed
to buy tesla with bitcoin because
there's
there's two sides to it you could either
make it could be a really smart
investment because then people pay with
bitcoin they sit on bitcoin
price of bitcoin goes to the roof they
make a lot of money
you paid talking about you paid a
hundred thousand
hundred thousand dollars worth of
bitcoin the next day yeah and then it
drops to half suddenly
what are you talking about i'm saying
it's a flip side as well because you
have
you're paying 100 that 100 turns into
200 percent
suddenly you're like oh crap hi you
missed the point here's the point with
that okay forget about
how volatile it's going to be there's a
risk there i guarantee you the board is
not happy with the volatile market of
bitcoin
i guarantee you that but you may also
buy a car for
sixty five thousand dollars that you
really paid a hundred thirty thousand
dollars no absolutely let's go both ways
exactly so so you know but the point is
this
give me the dna of a tesla buyer
i mean it's the wall street bets the
crypto kind of person the follower
they're they're weird they're different
yeah they're like i'm not like you
i don't want to be like you i'm
different i don't buy what you buy you
guys are dummies that buy or whatever
they think everybody else is weird
no no no they think the rest of the
world that doesn't drive a tesla you're
a
fool you know that's how they're wired
they're wired
they have like a secret that you don't
know about they're part of a community
you're not part of a community
you okay all right if tesla drivers are
like that
what other investors are like that
cryptocurrency
exactly yeah they just they just they
just got the entire cryptocurrency
community which is a massive one to say
dude i'm gonna go buy this and they're
now gonna be screaming off the top of
their lungs
which is their community it is their
community so
they just recruited an entire community
of pro tesla and you know what else
about the crypto guys let me ask you a
question do you know people that
love oil all they do is they do oil
investments
many i'm an opec guy yeah yeah that's
what i'm saying i'm an oil man do you
know people that
are big real estate guys
yeah do you know people that are big you
know value stock guys that they want to
buy disney that's 10
down how many of those guys are louder
than bitcoin guys
nobody that's combined you want the
loudest customer to be on your side they
just got the loudest customers
that are now tesla's bitcoin people are
like vegans they're gonna
whether you want to know you're gonna
know that they're bitcoin people yeah
they're
they're they're gonna let you know guys
are we having some problems or no
you just had the best part that we had
some problems man this was awesome
audio is going or no did it cut off or
no because we dropped a little bit
okay i got it okay so that's good so
okay we back it's back fixed come back
okay sounds still there okay good so
so yeah my my answer to you with that is
very simple
bitcoin is officially all fan of
tesla yeah so they won in so many
different ways
no i think i think obviously it's a it's
a different one but do you think
tesla will use the bitcoin or do you
think they'll sit on it just as a
sort of investment kind of i think
they're going to sit on it if you ask me
yeah i don't think i
i'd agree i think they're going to sit
on it it's a great question
which is i think the bitcoin's last
hurdle
yeah i think is how it works with taxes
and taxation of it because
it's a decentralized platform you buy it
you have to know at that point
when your tesla their board is
ridiculous brilliant people with their
board and their accounting and their
audited financials i'm sure i'm sure
they're able to do it but it's still
as a from what i've understood when you
buy and sell
cryptocurrency you're obliged to
yourself kind of report what you've made
or how the money works with that and
you're kind of uh you're giving the
the irs the information yourself so
obviously you could say
oh i didn't make ten thousand i made a
thousand or even
i didn't make any money at all and they
wouldn't know so i think that's more
where could it be interesting with tesla
it'll work
because obviously they'll do it the
question is just with people that put
money into it
because unless you're paying for it with
a good
like you're trading it into other goods
then that's kind of where the taxation
comes in
if you're just buying it to invest and
to have it multiply and stuff like that
as an asset source
then that's different because then it's
one transaction it's more when
you go from the bitcoin to the to normal
currency as a
form of trade that's kind of where it
can get a little bit tricky which is why
it would be harder
or delayed until we can have people be
paying with bitcoin for normal
transactions
in everyday life you you don't think
they've thought
thought that out and had a process made
for that and kind of looked at all the
good bad and the ugly
no i'm sure i'm sure they've that and
obviously if like they're that's what
they're trying to figure out now of
why you have visa and paypal and all
these people like what what can we do
how can we
elan is a paypal partner paypal mafia he
knows he's been around the block with
this stuff exactly and he's i'm sure
he's in the forefront of being able to
figure out how you can do it
in in a manner i think it's just more
another hurdle for
the main street guy that would have to
figure that's a good point how am i
going to do that i think that's a good
point so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye